la-la-land was directed by Damien
Chazelle and stars Ryan Gosling and Emma
Stone and this was one of the films I
got to see at the AFI Fest premiere
which was a ton of fun this film is a
modern-day musical where Ryan Gosling is
a jazz piano player who has a lot of
passion for this style of music and Emma
Stone is an aspiring actress who meets
him and they begin to fall for each
other and their story is told through
musical form whether it's dancing or
singing now Damien Chazelle first film
whiplash was one of my favorite movies
of 2014 I gave it my highest grade of a
plus I have not one single problem with
that movie so obviously I was really
excited to see this movie plus it has my
dude in it mr. Gosling I like him he's a
good talented actor and once again
shizzle has made another film centered
around music even his script for the
movie grand piano is about a pianist
pianist I'm 12 that movie's a better
piano player that's been told if he hits
a wrong note he's gonna get sniped by
John Cusack so clearly shows ellas
inspired by music and that's very clear
with his direction of this movie which
is manically frenetic such fast paced
editing beautiful long tapes of dance
sequences that unfold seamlessly this is
one of the best directed films of the
year I am very pleased with how great
la-la-land turned out and I'm not
necessarily the biggest fan of musicals
I would say if I were to pick a genre in
film that was my least favorite it would
probably be musicals but that didn't
stop me from loving this film because of
just how well made it is a lot of people
are describing this film as a love
letter to LA I heartily disagree this
film at every turn pokes fun at the
absurdities and the pretentiousness of
that town every chance it gets the film
does this Emma Stone will be on an
audition and no one's paying attention
to her no one's giving her respect Ryan
Gosling is a very passionate piano
player and he can't play what he really
wants to play he can only get these jobs
playing jingle bells at various
restaurants know this film is a love
letter to passionate people people who
have dreams people who want to succeed
in doing what they love someone who is
going - no matter what anyone says plow
ahead that's what this films a love
letter - not a town la is beautiful in
this movie it looks incredible the way
it's shot particularly one incredible
sequence where Gosling and stone dance
and sing in front of a beautiful la
sunset this is a movie that is grabbing
the shoulders of anyone who is
passionate out there shaking them and
telling them to get out there and follow
their dreams
I personally related to goslings angry
love for jazz in this movie and I say
angry because there's this one scene
where he's sitting emmastone down at a
jazz club and forcing her to listen to
jazz the way he hears it and he's just
so passionate about it he's screaming
about how no one appreciates this music
for what it is because according to Emma
Stone it's just one of those smooth jazz
things that people put on the radio in
the background at parties and goslings
like no no no you have no idea what
you're talking about and I love how
passionate he is about it and I related
to Emma Stone's incredible desire to
want to be an actress not to be an
actress
or do I mmm again I'm 12 but she just
has this never-ending well of passion
that she just keeps digging into to try
to find and follow her dreams to sum up
what I love about this movie besides its
technical qualities and its excellent
performances it's that this movie
genuinely wants people to achieve their
dreams and it's a movie made by someone
who clearly feels that he has and since
this filmmaker is almost my age he's
young enough to understand what it feels
like to really want your dreams out
there and feel like maybe you're just
it's just right there and you just have
to reach a little farther and you can
attain it and it's told through really
great musical numbers that never got on
my nerves when characters start singing
and dancing in this film it feels like a
natural progression of the scene that
we're already watching it never feels
like hey now's the part where we sing
and I hope you like a you don't
like it well um sorry but the film also
wisely understands that sacrifices have
to be made along the way and it doesn't
shy away from the pain that can be
involved sometimes when you have so many
things on your plate and it's just too
difficult to balance all of them I think
la-la-land is one of the best musicals
ever made I think whiplash is the better
film that I will watch more often but
nevertheless I found lava land to be
extremely entertaining it's a career
best performance from Emma Stone and
just another notch and Ryan Gosling's
belt of Awesomeness i'm gonna give lala
land and a definitely check this one out
guys even if you don't like musicals I
think it's worth your time thank you
very much as always for watching and if
you like this you can click right here
and get steppen eyes